[Music]
it's really hard to describe how i feel
i cannot put it into words you never
know what it means to see the home you
built
reduced to ruins
[Music]
we are living in fear there is no
security
i wish we could just freeze time
[Music]
the aim is to cleanse the area of
palestinians entirely
this is part of israel's holy basin plan
for jerusalem
which starts at sheikh jarrah and ends
here in silwan passing through the
ancient town
it is nothing short of ethnic cleansing
it is a plan to uproot the palestinians
from their lands and replace them with
jewish settlers
[Music]
[Music]
there are some 20 homes or buildings
in total that are at threat of
imminently getting
such a demolition order because they
were built after
a law which makes it much more difficult
to challenge this kind of thing in the
courts
there are another 48 cases currently
going through the courts and there are
more besides
that are under threat so this is a major
threat to a major part
of palestinian life here
[Music]
we're obviously following these recent
developments
in east jerusalem including in the
al-bustan neighborhood extremely closely
the secretary general is indeed deeply
concerned by the continued demolitions
he once again reiterates his call to the
israeli authorities to end demolitions
and evictions
in line with israel's obligations under
international
humanitarian and international human
rights
law
you